it's going on too long like the Irishman
yeah it could it could be edited yeah
yeah it needs an editor of this war at
this point I almost thought of going I
was in Romania I almost sort of going to
the Ukraine you're gonna get tickets I
was gonna go to the Ukraine and go is it
even happening here yeah but then people
said it is that 30 of their
infrastructure is done so I said okay
like he's hitting them hard yeah water
power they don't have Wi-Fi Putin's
hitting them now yeah he's hitting them
hard he's hitting him he's hitting him
with the artillery right it could be
Iranian drones or it could be his own
drones all I know is our media is
telling us it's Iranian drones whatever
it is yeah we don't know well because
there was that whole thing in Iran where
I don't know what that was but everyone
was posting about it that woman in Iran
something happened to her and that was
sad oh [ __ ] are you talking about the
revolution happening over there yeah
yeah that's kind of dragging on too
what is it she had a cloak on and she
said I don't want to do it today yeah
maybe she had uh the I always pronounce
it wrong
good job hijab on yeah you had the job
on and um oh she didn't have it on what
she took it off she took it off and
that's a No-No over there you gotta keep
it up it's a no no over there to take it
off over here it's a rah-rah to put it
on put it on and you're in you're in
baby Nike commercial you're getting a
book deal yeah so she took it off what
happened acid in the face hey something
like that okay yeah who knows yeah I
mean you know it could have been acid in
the face by the way the gas station
Producer instead of like finding
articles where this stuff's happening
he's just trying to sign into his email
he's just he's just oh there she is
that's sad well that well now you're
bumming us out we don't want that well
that's a bummer what happened what's
that
that's a big bummer she's laying there
in the hospital we're trying to do a
comedy show I'm trying to do a comedy
podcast we don't need a picture of her
in the hospital that doesn't help maybe
the sponsors won't like that we're
trying to sell underwear here for fat
people
he just maybe thought we were more
visual do we know what happened to her
good old producer do we know it's
they're saying she had a heart attack at
a police station collapsed and fell into
a coma but
that doesn't seem to be uh she died I
think that's yeah boy she's like their
in their in their Revolution right now
that she's like they're George Floyd
right I think one whoa I think once now
I get it yeah one side's going hey she
fell
and the other side's going like I don't
think she fell
one side's going like one side's going
let's go it's fentanyl oh God I don't
think it was I saw a nine minute video
where a guy was going I can't breathe
and you were kneeing on his neck I think
that had something to do with it well
somebody sent me him swallowing a bag of
drugs oh Floyd I don't know if that's
true or not nope it could be someone
sent me something yeah someone that but
the knee on the neck probably didn't
help never good never good so this woman
is Iran's George Floyd right that now
you've put it in context for me only way
for us to understand because I've never
knew yes and she had a heart attack at
the police she fell which is a real
unfortunate series of events or yeah
something else happened and that's why
Iran is it's really heating up yeah she
was you know doing the equivalent of
cashing yeah so here we go again however
eyewitnesses including women who were
detained with amini reportedly said she
was severely beaten and that she died as
a result of police brutality which is
probably true I or it's probably true
depends on who you ask or not she fell
into the stairs it could have been
because maybe they're but maybe it
wasn't that right right I'm I'm I I
would guess it wasn't that really yeah I
would guess because they don't take too
kindly to uh women taking off so you're
saying she was beaten I'm saying there's
a chance there's a chance there's a
chance she was beat yeah to death I
suspect probably yeah I suspect there's
a chance here okay I'd say I'd say that
there's a good chance because
um yeah I I guess well by the way
whatever that is we're not hey you know
we're on our we we think that that is
abhorrent and it should uh be we should
we should uh do something I don't know
what we should do we should uh maybe
make another commercial about it well I
you know there's got to be a way this
would be a perfect time for Nike to make
a follow-up commercial of of her or of
something in Iran no some with how
important it is to wear the hijab to
wear the hijab yeah and play tennis or
something yeah it would be this would be
a perfect timing for it yeah don't miss
this opportunity yeah this is like the
six months right after 9 11. this is
like True Crimes and instead of just do
it when you're about to take the hijab
off Nike could go think about it
are you sure you want to do that you
don't have to it doesn't have to just do
it it could be sink it over don't think
about it think about it yeah think about
it there's a lot of history there
there's a lot of tradition on your head
that you are now taking off it's your
choice put it on put it off that's
that's all you ask so the commercial
should be someone putting it on to play
tennis that's right but then you show
her taking it off yeah and she doesn't
fall into the stairs yeah or she's about
to take it off and then she starts
thinking about her mother and
grandmother right and society and that
their rules do need to kind of be in
place right and she realizes that at the
end of the day the best thing she can do
is go along with the plan right right
because sometimes that's just enough
it's a nice thing to do yeah so that's
what's going on over there that's what's
going on is that the women what was the
other thing and I got to be honest and
this is gonna probably make me sound
like insensitive here
it's like
you don't have to wear the full one
right no but it's like like I get what
you're saying it's like okay you guys
are a little upset you can't take them
off if you want to but we got a wage Gap
here
yeah so so like everyone's got problems
nothing's perfect it's like well here's
what I I always go this isn't my culture
yeah it's this is when people get angry
at me they're like no you don't
understand it's not my culture right so
the reality is I don't tell them what to
do right because I don't it's not we're
not nothing to do with anything and also
that would be wrong of you today it
would be wrong it would be wrong it's
pumpkin fat Whitey telling them but
here's the deal yeah I don't go into
sub-Saharan Africa where they're lobbing
off cliffs and making stew and tell them
what to do is that what I would do no no
Anthony Bourdain would it would be rude
for him not to taste it he would go and
eat it yeah I just say let people do
what they do and it would be it would be
what what is it I don't medal it would
be what's it ethnocentric yes it would
be ethnocentric to assume yeah that you
can say what's right or wrong but it
kind of would I know we're being
sarcastic but here's the deal what are
we supposed to do in Vape no and can
convince everyone to not lob the clits
off and make the stew no what's the
point no whatever makes you happy we're
supposed to whatever makes you happy we
send weapons we have a defense industry
that needs to unload something I don't
like that you could the Ukraine was a
country of white Nazis and we've somehow
made it into like it's a RuPaul's Drag
Race well but all this sexuality was
like basically illegal there up until 20
minutes ago when it's now the most
gay-friendly country uh of an ex-sovia
country we just lie about what all these
things are anyway but I'm sure there's a
few Nazis in Russia too
for sure but Ukraine it was like a
massive thing there was all kinds of
things that they pulled down videos it's
just they're into it yeah it's
propaganda
what we should do something about this
thing when they say Russians are being
armed with Viagra to rape ukrainians
that feels fake
that feels like propaganda I would sue
if I was Viagra I mean Russians are
being on like they're doing poorly on
the battlefield anyway and they're going
by the way if you have extra time go
rape someone yeah that seems like it's a
little wacky does this go into World War
III you know a lot about history perhaps
yeah perhaps ugly